[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing one
of the most hated characters from the
entire series
no it's not vernon dursley and no it's
not voldemort
it's none other than dolores jane
umbridge
hogwarts high inquisitor proud ministry
employee
and head of the muckleborn registration
commission
more specifically however we're going to
be digging into umrich's past
and uncovering her humble beginnings was
she always awful
who were her parents where did she grow
up why was she so prejudiced
sit back relax and enjoy the life of
dolores jane umbridge
now before we get started i just want to
refute one thing
umbridge did not hail from the selwyn
family
in the deathly hallows while serving as
head of the muggle-born registration
commission
dolores claimed that the s on the
necklace around her neck
stood for selwyn that's that's pretty
dolores
she said pointing at the pendant
gleaming in the ruffled folds of
umbridge's blouse
what snapped umbridge glancing down oh
yes an old family heirloom
she said patting the locket lying on her
large bosom
the s stands for selwyn i'm related to
the selwyns
indeed there are few pureblood families
to whom
i am not related while this was probably
more of a distraction tactic
rather than a genuine claim she still
said it and i want to make it perfectly
clear
that umbridge was not related to the
selwyns in fact
she wasn't related to any pureblood
families at all
the truth is umbridge was a half-blood
part of her existence that she tried
very hard to hide dolores umbridge was a
british half-blood witch
born sometime before the year 1965.
before 1965 is a bit vague but that's
all we're given
so she could have been 31 when starting
working at hogwarts
or 61. it's quite unclear she was a
short woman with a broad flowery face
little neck and slack mouth resembling a
toad
she was born in the british isles to one
magical and one muggle parent
her family was quite small her father
was a wizard by the name of orford
umbridge
and her mother was a muggle named ellen
cracknell and her younger brother's name
is never actually revealed
isn't it interesting how the department
head for the muggle-born registration
commission
was in fact a muggleborn herself dolores
family and home life was already very
dysfunctional and so it didn't help that
her father
her magical parent had very little
ambition perfectly happy to work as a
floor mopper
at the ministry of magic later in life
when dolores worked at the ministry
herself
she was occasionally questioned about
her relationship to the floor mopper at
the ministry
a connection that she would vehemently
deny in fact is later revealed that
those who did question her identity
or her father's almost always had nasty
things
happen to them nasty things tended to
happen to people who asked about orford
or anything that dolores did not like
talking about and people who wanted to
remain on her good side
pretended to believe her version of her
ancestry i'm sure you could only imagine
what a terrible and judgmental person
like umbridge
would think of a floor mopper however
dolores wasn't the root cause of all of
the issues in her family
in fact i think it was her father that
ended up being the root cause of the
family's problems
as he actively blamed dolores mother for
birthing a squib
the squib in question of course being
dolores brother
whose name is never revealed despite
having very little ambition
having a squib child was a source of
shame for him and the main focal point
for all of the family's troubles
this was undoubtedly an unhealthy
environment for dolores to grow up in
and i have no doubt that it contributed
to turning her into the dysfunctional
woman
that she would become i'll continue
discussing her family later on
but for now let's jump into umbridge's
earlier years
and her proper introduction to magic
like so many before
and after her at age 11 it was time for
umbridge to start planning to head to
hogwarts
the finest school of witchcraft and
wizardry in the world
at least according to hagrid when they
come of age all young witches and
wizards should expect a hogwarts
acceptance letter
even the ones like umbridge the hogwarts
acceptance letter informs new students
of their acceptance
to hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry and along with the letter
includes a list of required textbooks
and materials
required for the upcoming school year
from this point students are required to
travel to diagon alley
and purchase the materials one of the
most important pieces of kit
of course being a wand for this
particular item
students know exactly where to go
ollivander's one shop
as we all know the one that chooses the
witch or wizard and what's even more
interesting is that you can actually
derive a lot about someone's personality
from their wand
when it came time for a wand to choose
dolores she ended up with an 8-inch
birch wand
the dragon heartstring core the first
thing that should pop out to you here
is that dolores wand is abnormally short
particularly
as olivender chiefly gives out ones
between 9 and 15 inches in length
while this short wand wouldn't mean much
coming from another want maker
it actually signifies a lot coming from
olivander
wand makers often match the wand length
to the height of the witch or wizard who
will use it
but ollivander considers this measure
inadequate in his experience
longer than average ones tend to be
drawn to those with a physical
peculiarity
or a bigger personality whereas
abnormally short ones
select people whose character lacks in
something what this tells us is that
even at age 11
dolores character was stunted especially
morally
or lacked something a short one
particularly an
abnormally short wand is certainly no
compliment
after collecting all of her school
supplies it was time for umrich to head
off to school
the hogwarts and so she travelled the
platform nine and three quarters
just like all the other children her age
after arriving at hogwarts it wasn't
long before the sorting ceremony began
the ceremony that decides which hogwarts
house you best fit into
what i'm sure won't surprise any of you
is that umbridge was sorted into
slytherin house
the house most commonly associated with
those that were morally dubious
umbridge was a good student and took
school very seriously
but because she clashed with her head of
house horus slughorn
she was never awarded any positions of
power i.e prefect
head girl etc despite possibly being
deserving of those positions
while she certainly isn't charming to
any degree
slughorn really didn't take to her and
once described her as
an idiotic woman her inability to garner
any positions of power or additional
responsibility at the school
in spite of her work ethic meant that
umbridge never enjoyed her time at
hogwarts
meanwhile home life for umbridge was
difficult as well and she grew to hate
each of her parents
more and more as she grew older in fact
the constant internal struggles the
family faced
eventually split them up dolores parents
were unhappily married
and dolores secretly despised both of
them offered for his lack of ambition
he had never been promoted and worked in
the department of magical maintenance at
the ministry of magic
and her mother ellen for her flightiness
untidiness
and muggle lineage both orford and his
daughter blamed ellen for dolores
brothers lack of magical ability
with the result that when dolores was 15
the family split down the middle
orford and dolores remaining together
and ellen vanishing back into the muggle
world with her son
dolores never saw her mother or brother
again never spoke of either of them
and henceforth pretended to all she met
that she was a pure blood
the family split while umrich was still
studying at hogwarts
at age 15 but at this stage she hated
them all so much that it didn't really
matter
instead of being sad about it she just
continued to focus on her studies
in the pursuit of one day achieving some
level of power
i do wonder though how the split would
have affected her mentally
that's by the time she was 15 she would
have known her mother
brother quite well not seeing them ever
again
must have been tough but then again this
is dolores umbridge we're talking about
after graduating from hogwarts umbridge
finally had an opportunity to receive
recognition for her work ethic
during her time at hogwarts her growth
was stunted by slughorn
largely because he didn't like her but
when she secured a job at the ministry
of magic
she climbed the ranks quickly she
started off as an intern at the improper
use of magic office
and by the time she was 30 10 or so
years later
she became head of that same department
umbridge achieved this role while still
very
young largely due to a combination of
three things
strong work ethic ruthlessness and an
outwardly
sweet demeanor when important however
despite having a strong work ethic
she certainly didn't play by the rules
and would often take credit for other
people's work
she was known for tyrannizing her
subordinates who she felt could offer
nothing to her
and being overly flattering towards her
superiors in the hopes that it would
further advance her career
basically she was a suck-up but the
sweet side that she would show to her
superiors
was of course entirely contrived of
course working at the ministry also
meant that she now worked in the same
place as her father
but as i mentioned earlier she denied
any affiliation with him
in fact she actually paid him off
offering him a monthly allowance to
simply get at a public site
she didn't want to risk any connections
being made this was the beginning of
dolores outrageous claims
regarding her pure blood status with her
father gone
and her ruthless nature she continued to
climb and climb the ranks of the
ministry
eventually becoming senior under
secretary to the minister for magic
even earning herself a spot in the
wizard gamut one thing that i've always
found interesting
is how umbridge established herself and
got started in the ministry
without her identity ever being properly
questioned in a world it had only just
recently begun to accept half-bloods and
muggle-borns as part of their society
it's curious that umbridge got by the
way that she did had she tried to enter
the ministry a century sooner
it's untelling how that would have gone
for her while working at the ministry
dolores did any and everything she could
to rise to the top of the career ladder
and this included looking for a
potential partner
repeatedly umbridge tried to garner the
affections of one of her superiors
in order to elevate her status but
everyone at the ministry found it quite
difficult to like her
in fact her prejudice viewpoint towards
certain groups basically anyone that
wasn't a pureblood human wizard
started to become obvious in fact in
umbridge passed anti-werewolf
legislation and in 1994
started a campaign calling for mer
people to be rounded up
and tagged soon umbridge would begin at
hogwarts
but before that happened we also of
course need to remember the incident in
little whinging
involving dementors you see since
becoming under secretary to the minister
for magic
fudge umbridge became reasonably close
with him only because they worked
directly together
as umbridge was a little bit deceitful
and undercutting
she took advantage of fudge's paranoia
surrounding the return
of the dark lord and took action to take
care of harry potter
who was insistent that voldemort had
returned in order to
silence harry she anonymously ordered
the dementor attack on dudley and harry
in little whinging
by sending dementors there she knew that
she would get her desired result either
way
if the dementor successfully kissed
harry then great
he would keep his mouth shut and if
harry used a patronus charm to get rid
of them then he could be expelled for
using magic in the presence of a muggle
it was a win-win for umbridge except not
because harry didn't end up getting
expelled
you see despite her presence at harry's
trial the court ended up voting in
harry's favor
and the charges were dropped however
this wasn't the last that harry saw of
umbridge
as not long after at hogwarts of all
places
they met again in 1995 disaster struck
hogwarts
for you see it was this year that
umbridge was appointed as the new
defense against the dark arts professor
umbridge was a poor teacher
mainly because she taught her own biased
and ineffective curriculum
however she didn't act in this role
alone for long as she was eventually
appointed as hogwarts first ever
high inquisitor a position that she used
to harass
students and peers however this power
still wasn't enough for umbridge
as dumbledore was still technically in
charge he
was headmaster during this time at the
ministry
namely fudge and dumbledore were
continually butting heads
fudge was lashing out he was blinded by
fear and in utter denial the dark lord
voldemort had returned
dumbledore continually tried to convince
fudge of the truth but his efforts were
futile
and fudge continued to punish dumbledore
in whatever way he could
eventually dolores umbridge and her
inquisitorial squad
discovered the headquarters of
dumbledore's army in the room of
requirement
dumbledore's army was of course formed
by harry and had nothing to do with
dumbledore
but with dumbledore's name in the
group's name fingers started to get
pointed at him
dumbledore happily took responsibility
for the formation of the group
claiming that it was all his idea and
that no student should be punished in
his place
after a minor scuffle with umbrage some
auras and fudge
dumbledore eventually left hogwarts this
after school without a headmaster
at this point umbridge passed
educational decree number 28
which effectively replaced dumbledore
with umbridge
umbridge was headmistress of hogwarts
this was a
dark dark time for the school arguably
as dark as when snape took over
but fortunately it didn't last long
umbridge ran a tight ship at hogwarts
which meant that
not a lot of illicit activity went
unnoticed so
when umbridge eventually saw an
opportunity to punish harry for
something
she jumped on it and even threatened him
with the cruciatus curse
in order to prevent harry from basically
being tortured by the school's new
headmistress
hermione decided to distract umbridge by
mentioning a
secret weapon of the order of the
phoenix from here
umrich was tricked into travelling to
the forbidden forest with harry and
hermione
at which point they were confronted by a
group of centaurs
umbridge arrogant and prejudiced as ever
didn't back down in their presence
and began to attack them this only
angered the centaurs
who already didn't like umbrage even
more and they subsequently snapped her
wand in half and captured her
umbrage was eventually saved by
dumbledore who the centaurs came to
respect
though she did hold a substantial fear
of centaurs for the rest of her life
with the irrefutable evidence pointing
to voldemort's return
dumbledore was reappointed as headmaster
and much the joy of the hogwarts
population
umbridge no longer had anything to do
with the school
amazingly however umbridge still found
herself for the job
after leaving hogwarts in fact the
ministry accepted her back in her
previous role
of senior undersecretary to the minister
of magic
also at this stage the ministry had a
new minister
rufus scrimga despite a brief appearance
at dumbledore's funeral the next we hear
of umbrage is in 1997
following voldemort's takeover of the
ministry in addition to her primary
position of under secretary
umbridge also became head of the
mughal-born registration commission
where she conducted trials that were
effectively designed to prosecute
muggleborns
while working at the ministry and the
voldemort's regime umbridge wore a
locket around her neck
a locket which turned out to be the
locket of salazar sidharin
the horcrux she received the locket as a
bribe from mandanga's fletcher
and didn't really know of his
significance or of the fact that it was
affecting her behavior
it made an already inseparable person
that much worse
and it only strengthened her extremist
ideals and hatred
toward groups which she disliked she
claimed that the locket was an heirloom
and that the s stood for selwyn the name
of a known pureblood family
but this was of course a lie like i
mentioned in the beginning of the video
eventually while working in her new role
umbridge once again came face to face
with hermione
ron and harry who were disguised as
ministry employees
they arrived at the active hearing of
muggle-born witch mary catamol
who was being unfairly prosecuted by
umbridge unable to contain his anger any
longer
harry ended up attacking umbridge and
corbin yaxley with a stunning spell
which allowed the trio to steal the
lockets from around her neck and flee
unfortunately however after the trio
escaped umbridge was left with free
reign to continue
unfairly prosecuting muggle-born witches
and wizards and presumably
she did so with a newfound fury having
been bested by the trio once again
umbridge doesn't appear much more in the
story after this as there are bigger
problems in the wizarding world
lord voldemort however with voldemort's
eventual downfall
the ministry once again came under
control of normal witches and wizards
expunging all of voldemort's followers
from positions of power
the ministry of magic essentially
underwent a reformation
headed by kingsley shakobolt who became
the new minister for magic
fully aware of the type of person that
umbridge was and the crimes that she had
committed
during voldemort's regime kingsley had
umbrage arrested
tried convicted and given a life
sentence to the island fortress
of azkaban ah don't you love a happy
ending
and that's it for this video i hope you
enjoyed it if you want more of these
life of style videos then let me know in
the comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
[Music]
harry
you